[Musique]
c'est bien aidé
si je peux oui
vous l'avez trouvé où il la main dans
les cinq premiers à avoir recruté du
premier coup à wall street
excusez moi mais mon travail c'est la
conformité des hasards vous avez fait
enregistrer ce rapport est empêché par
là même une entreprise pesant plus de 7
milliards de dollars de faire affaire
avec nous il veut réaffectant région
dans une des nos succursales
elle bat new york c'est là que j'ai
quand est ce que tu peux par là je
devrais pas voir ça au contraire il faut
que tu vois ça qu'est ce qui nous vaut
le plaisir tu l'as pas parler aux
propriétaires faut que tu vois ça marty
bonne numéro de téléphone pas dit mais
juste une boîte à remplir 10 millions
c'est pas un petit investissement
il me semblait que c'était un mythe
saloperies genre terrorisme trafics
d'armes trafic d'êtres humains et bien
mec je te vois partout tu me suivent
quoi ouais l'arc à un [ __ ] de vrais
problèmes je suis pratiquement sûr que
la mafia russe blanchi de l'argent via
la succursale d'omni
c'est pas si mal que ça en fait
[Musique]
c'est quoi les héros